[Music]
this isn't funny amber would you like to
play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are i've been through
this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
[Music]
you ready
for this
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello it's an honor
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
[Music]
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
you see umbrella they have an incident
i'm talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
shall we go
[Music]
this is where they're experimenting on
them
should split up
[Music]
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
all right whenever you're ready
we are shooting a documentary because i
am about to meet my first biological
relative
she's amish i'm not i am not honest
we are humbled and grateful to have our
sister margot return to us
i've always hoped that i could meet you
all so this is a really special moment
for me
hey
mind if i film you for a moment
uh hey
[Music]
i like your doll
what's her name
yeah
you know that was my mom's name
she used to live here a long time ago
she's still here
what did you say
whoa
why would they build a church all the
way back here
what is that the demon asmodeus was
trapped inside a chosen woman of god
this has happened before
what the hell
are these from my mom
you can't have me and my baby
i know every i was family within a
50-mile area
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh my god are you sure about this
i have to know
[Music]
[Music]
what is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story
they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on
we found a part of a man in the woods
today
[Music]
part of the man
i guess the other half was found in the
mine
all this has got to be an animal right
[Music]
no animal i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth
for you yeah
when knocking again
[Music]
he's here
we've been gifted this beautiful house
we live here
can you believe it
[Music]
they've wanted to keep the place in your
family jamie
we really appreciate the house
well then you know
it's got a hole in the roof the wheels
they'll do a good job jamie
you just carry on with your day as if we
weren't here
there is one thing i need to show you
and it's a little bit peculiar
every evening before sunset she'd leave
a blood offering here sorry did you say
blood
for who
for the red caps
[Music]
they'll need feeding
you'll be hungry
can i get in my own house please you
want a deer how many times have english
come to this country and told us what
areas is now theirs
they need to know their place
what did you leave out tonight oh shoot
you can't miss a single day
[Music]
is anyone there
i can't be scared not in my own house
don't leave your wrists alone with the
lads
[Music]
we just came here for some peace
michael
i've known you since you were a child
you the gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
it's happening
i went from time
to feeling more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up doc
i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
you wouldn't comment you don't actually
believe that story do you because he
can't hear you and he doesn't really
take kids that say
beautiful isn't that just peachy cute
you need some help you see that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of ones in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
hello
don't hang up
who are you
you
know you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore a long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen you before except in my dreams
you don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fan
step right up in the behold one of the
unexplained mysteries of the universe is
he man or beast
[Music]
this creature
has been examined by the former
scientists and pronounce unequivocally
a man
i am prepared to offer you folks
one last chance
to witness the supreme oddity
where did it come from
forgotten by the same lust and threat
that got us all walking on this earth
but gone wrong somehow in maternal
wounds
[Music]
is it a beast
what is it a man
come on in
and find out
is he man or beast
[Music]
apparently it's very difficult to access
at the bottom of this part of the lake
there's a perfectly preserved house
let's go
there she is
[Music]
[Music]
what is that
when you're alone and life is making you
lonely you can always go
downtown
when you've got troubles all the noise
in the hurry seems to
[Music]
just listen to the music of the traffic
in the city
[Music]
linger on the sidewalks where the neon
signs are pretty how can you lose
[Music]
[Music]
the lights are much brighter there you
can forget all your troubles we get all
your care so go
downtown
things will be grey when you're
downtown
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone's waiting for you
[Music]
do you believe in ghosts
[Music]
[Music]
hey what are you guys doing out here
it's halloween we've been
trick-or-treating are you alone there's
a creepy man in a white mask
where
and he keeps like trying to play hide
and seek with us where did you see him
oh my god
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
we killed michael
my grandmother set the fire
no one told you
tell me what
40 years ago the boogeyman came for us
we are the survivors of michael myers
what do we do we fight
mom or family we'll kill him we're gonna
hunt him down and we're gonna put an end
to this
he is not gonna stop killing until we
stop him
if you track michael's victims that's a
straight line
to michael's childhood home
someone's in our house
he's coming for me
but i'm coming for him
i want to take his mask off and see the
life of leave his eyes
[Music]
you